une polémique qui éclipse pour certains
écologistes les vrais enjeux notamment
le réchauffement climatique ou encore le
partage de l'eau depuis le début de la
semaine TV Tour suit le convoi de l'eau
ce millier d'opposants au Méga bassines
agricoles aujourd'hui une halte en
Loir-et-Cher mer ce soir pour dénoncer
la bétonisation des terres et Blois
juste avant ou s'est rendu Lukas Chopin
12h45 aujourd'hui le convoi de l'eau
pénètre dans la ville de Blois sous les
applaudissements des habitants si la
construction des méga bassines symbolise
le point de départ de la manifestation
pour les militants cette étape Loire et
chaérienne et surtout une occasion de
mettre en exergue et de dénoncer le
traitement réservé à l'eau dans le
département on a un gros sujet qui est
l'agro-industrie qui salue qui salit et
consomme énormément d'eau donc ça c'est
un gros gros sujet puisqu'en plus notre
ministre de l'Agriculture et de chez
nous donc on se sent d'autant plus
impactés on a la bosse au dessus
[Musique]